wie sehen Sie die Situation in
Deutschland momentan zuerst gab es ja
Probleme mit unserem Kanzler und dem
Präsidenten dann gab es eine Zeit da
wurden die Beziehungen besser
Situation
und jetzt ja ist großer ich sage Ihnen
meine persönliche Meinung Deutschland
ist ein absolut zuverlässiger und
hilfreicher Partner für die Ukraine
obwohl es für Deutschland schwieriger
scheint die neue Realität anzuerkennen
als für andere europäische Länder
die Menschen in Deutschland verstehen
immer noch nicht die Intensität des
Krieges den Russland führt und ich
betone das Russland an unserer
Frontlinie eine gigantische Anzahl von
schweren Fahrzeugen und Waffen
konzentriert hat
kein Land in Europa käme mit dieser
Menge klar es gibt keinen Zweifel dass
die Ukraine maximale Unterstützung
benötigt es mag paradox klingen je mehr
militärische unter Unterstützung die
Ukraine von ihren führenden Partnern
bekommt in erster Linie von Deutschland
desto schneller wird der Krieg enden und
dadurch würden auch die russischen
Auswirkungen auf die europäische
Wirtschaft drastisch abnehmen den
Energiesektor eingeschlossen
in Deutschland fragen sich die Menschen
wenn wir mehr zahlen als Russland also
wenn es unserer Wirtschaft mehr schadet
heute das scheint mir nicht die richtige
Fragestellung zu sein sicherlich steht
die deutsche Regierung unter Druck ihren
Wählern gegenüber das verstehen wir aber
wir müssen zeigen dass die Demokratie
auch in Krisensituationen stabiler ist
als der Totalitarismus das ist übrigens
ein weiterer Grund warum Russland
verlieren muss wir müssen beweisen dass
die totalitären Regime komplett
handlungsunfähig sind im Vergleich zu
Demokratien
wenn Russland gewinnt werden sich andere
totalitäre Systeme ermutigt fühlen
aggressiver zu sein das führt zu mehr
Instabilität in der ganzen Welt
haben sie eine klare Strategie auf jeden
Fall und welche muss wir sind nicht die
Russische Föderation wir analysieren
alles genau was auf dem Schlachtfeld
geschieht wir vergleichen die
Bereitstellung der Ressourcen der
ukrainischen und der russischen Armee
und die technischen Möglichkeiten
unsere Strategie ist entlang der
gesamten Frontlinie klar erkennbar sie
lautet Zerstörung der logistischen
Versorgung der russischen Armee
im Hinterland der russischen Armee kommt
es zur Explosionen an Standorten von
Kampffahrzeugen Flugzeugen Hubschraubern
in Munitionsdepots und großen
treibstofflagern
außerdem nehmen die Proteste seitens der
Krim Tataren immer mehr zu sie lebten
acht Jahre lang unter einem starken
Druck des russischen Geheimdienstes FSB
einige Menschen verschwanden andere
landeten für 20 bis 30 Jahre im
Gefängnis und vieles mehr all das
spiegelt die Strategie der Ukraine
wieder sie ist auf die stetige
Verdrängung der russischen Streitkräfte
vom ukrainischen Gebiet gerichtet
Priester
Dortmund es steht für uns fest dass
Russland die Gebiete innerhalb der
international anerkannten ukrainischen
Grenzen räumen muss das ist der einzige
Weg zu einem bilateralen Abkommen
welchen auch immer mit einschlägigen
garantienseitens unserer Partner
nicht wenige Analysten in Deutschland
fordern derzeit sofort diesen Krieg zu
beenden sich an den Tisch zu setzen und
einen Kompromiss zu finden
mir scheint Deutschland muss strengere
Anforderungen an seine Analytiker
stellen sonst wird Deutschland die
Ereignisse immer falsch deuten und unter
den Verlusten die daraus entstehen
leiden die Analysen müssen objektiv sein
und auf präzisen und korrekten
Informationen beruhen es ist komplett
unmöglich dass wir heute mit der
Russischen Föderation verhandeln denn
Russland glaubt es habe das Recht einen
Massenmord an den Bürgern eines anderen
Landes zu begehen auf den Territorium
meines souveränen Staates wenn wir also
heute mit Russland verhandeln dann
werden wir seinen Sieg anerkennen und
weiteres Territorium verlieren außerdem
wird die Ukraine nicht in der Lage sein
ihre Bürger in die Städte
zurückzubringen das bedeutet wir wären
nicht in der Lage 12 Millionen
vertriebene Menschen zurückzubringen und
zum Schluss wird Russland sich in Europa
aggressiv verhalten da es sich als
Gewinner betrachtet es wird Europa
herabwürdigen
hier wurde
wie lange wollen Sie diesen Krieg noch
führen
wenn Sie der Meinung sind dass die
Aussichten für Verhandlungen bei Null
liegen
wie die Perspektive narasco wurde
sie stellen die richtige Frage und es
gibt eine richtige Antwort die
ukrainische Gesellschaft hat eine
übereinstimmende Entscheidung getroffen
dass sie bereit ist diesen Krieg so
lange zu führen wie es nötig ist um
unser Land zu befreien es gibt keine
anderen Optionen es herrscht ein
öffentlicher Konsens darüber es ist
keine politische Entscheidung keine
alleinige Entscheidung des Präsidenten
oder unsere Armee es ist die
Entscheidung unserer Gesellschaft wir
mussten uns Live-Bilder ansehen die uns
das Unvorstellbare Ausmaß von
Kriegsverbrechen deutlich machten unsere
Menschen wurden grausam ermordet
darunter Kinder und schwangere Frauen
durch einen Genickschuss deshalb wirkt
auf mich die Frage befremdlich zu
welchen Kompromisslösungen wir bereit
wären um einem Kriegsverbrecher zu
gestatten der Strafe für seine Taten zu
entgehen
wenn die Kriegsverbrecher nicht bestraft
werden fassen Sie das als ihr Recht auf
in jedes andere Land einzumarschieren
und dasselbe dort anzurichten Russland
das systematisch unsere zivile
Bevölkerung vernichtete muss im Rahmen
internationaler Rechtsverfahren zum
Beispiel Tribunalen bestraft werden wir
müssen den Krieg gewinnen dann werden
die Werte die in Europa in den letzten
70 Jahren vertreten wurden ein neues
Gewicht bekommen Europa wird tatsächlich
einen starken Impuls zur weiteren
Entwicklung bekommen wir werden dafür
jetzt einen Preis zahlen die Ukraine
wird mit den Leben ihrer Menschen einen
viel höheren Preis zahlen Europa wird
einen erheblichen wirtschaftlichen Preis
zahlen aber wir verstehen wofür wir ihn
zahlen wir zahlen für ein gutes Ende
dieses Krieges die Ukraine ist bereit
bis zum Ende zu gehen ich würde mir
wünschen Europa und vor allem
Deutschland würden erkennen wie wichtig
es ist bis zum Ende zu gehen
das ist verständlich aber wann ist das
Ende wann der Krieg vorbei ist ist eher
eine Rechenaufgabe
aber nicht bald warum nicht da liegen
sie falsch eine gewisse Anzahl von
definierten militärischen Ausrüstung mit
einer gewissen Reichweite wird uns
ermöglichen diesen Krieg sehr schnell
und effektiv zu beenden
aber das ist doch momentan nicht
realistisch warum nicht realistisch zu
Beginn des Krieges haben so scheint mir
nur die wenigsten europäischen
Regierungen geglaubt dass der Krieg
mittlerweile 195 Tage dauern würde jeder
dachte dass es unrealistisch sei dem
Druck einer Armee wieder russischen
Stand zu halten und wo sind wir heute in
Kiew wo finden heute Kämpfe statt bei
denen die russischen Feinde immer weiter
herausgedrängt werden im Osten und Süden
der Ukraine und das wird weitergehen
dieser Krieg kann in einem Monat beendet
werden das hängt von der richtigen
militärischen Versorgung ab das ist
alles
gut vielen Dank ich danke Ihnen